hello everyone welcome to today's
broadcast the impact of precise medicine
on the practice of classical pathology
what are some of the challenges and
opportunities I'm Brenda Kelly Kim of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab groups the leading
scientific social networking site for
science professionals and provider of
educational web seminars for more
information please visit www m we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event questions can
be submitted by clicking the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to get to
as many of your questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
web seminar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process for obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Michael J Donovan dr.
Donovan PhD MD is a board-certified
anatomic and clinical pathologist with
sub specialty boards in pediatric
pathology in addition to an academic
career at Harvard Medical School in
Boston Children's Hospital dr. Donovan
was in the biotechnology space for over
15 years and has worked with a variety
of companies including millennium
pharmaceuticals Genentech insight and
most recently served as the chief
scientific officer for Ariane
Biosciences and the chief medical
officer of exone diagnostics spearheaded
the noodle ization multi
flex tissue and fluid based assays and
coupled mathematic applications to
produce clinically relevant diagnostic
predictive and prognostic outcome models
for a variety of tumor types and disease
states dr. Donovan is currently the
director of the biorepository at Sinai
and is the director of the experimental
pathology program across Mount Sinai I
will now turn it over to dr. Donovan for
his presentation
hi everyone this is dr. Michael Donovan
I'm speaking today from Mount Sinai and
I'm going to be speaking about
translational precision pathology so
hopefully everyone can see the slides
and we'll proceed and I think if you
have any questions you're able to submit
those questions to me online so
everything hopefully will be fine we'll
see how it goes so today will be a bit
different than probably past
presentations on this particular topic
because I'm focusing on the impact that
the clinical genomics age is having on
pathology departments and how this can
be best managed through a variety of
novel technologies and approaches that I
think will be important to be able to
redefine some of the attributes of
phenotyping patients and making this a
more effective process so some of the
agenda items that will cover today is
reviewing personalized medicine and the
challenges that this has an affecting
tumor interrogation and characterization
which is critical obviously in pathology
efforts the era of what I call a
next-gen pathology department and what
that will look like in the future and
how we will as pathologists meet those
needs of the future the impact of tumor
heterogeneity on the entire diagnostic
prognostic and predictive process and
how there are additional tools that can
be brought to bear in the context of to
Merle heterogeneity the role of the
liquid biopsy and just to touch upon
what that is and some of the new
technologies that are out there and how
they can be deployed in the clinical
setting and then some future programs
that will be covering here at Mount
Sinai specifically surrounding the
liquid biopsy piece so with everyone I
think understands that medicine has
always been personalized we treat
patients we diagnose patients but
reading the disease phenotype has been
somewhat challenging and as the slide
illustrates going from
the organ system brain rung bone
reproductive cycle gastrointestinal GI
tract that the goat taking that through
to the molecular side has been the
challenge that we're all faced I think
in terms of trying to really understand
that phenotype decipher what is
happening at the biochemical physiologic
level and then impact on that in some
way specifically as it relates to the
disease process at hand so of quite a
while ago now in 2011 Kenna Hammond Bob
Weinberg had looked at the hallmarks of
cancer as sort of i think the pillars of
what we are focusing on in pretty much
all of our strategies in terms of
understanding the proliferative cycle
evading growth reset suppressors
resisting cell death investigating
angiogenesis replicative immortality and
invasion and metastasis are some of the
main characteristics that we look at
from signaling pathway perspective and
then all of the attributes that those
play and what roles they actually can be
incorporated in disease manifestation
and this has really driven a lot of the
activities in biology today and in
clinical medicine with some specific
attributes and I'm going to try this
little function here to look at areas
like genome genome stability it's one of
those variables as well as tumor
promoting information so as I think
everyone has appreciated that genomic
analysis has really driven some of the
changes in terms of our phenotyping
capabilities and then most recently has
been the attack on the immune system and
the checkpoint inhibitors in the role
that they play and our understanding of
the infiltrate within disease processes
has evolved over time and that does have
become significant components that I
think we need to further understand and
evaluate if there have been some very
important elements that have driven a
lot of our understanding of disease
especially at the cancer level and the
Cancer Genome Atlas is the next slide
here illustrates some of these processes
going from tissue source through the
analysis aspect and then generating
sequencing data that in combination with
clinical data has driven
some of our understanding of disease as
you can probably imagine there are
limitations in the approach itself that
they are limited by the number of
samples you have their limited by the
types of samples that you will get in
these processes you're restricted in
some degree by the clinical data that's
associated with it so those do present
barriers but overall it has helped to
collectively understand some of the
tumor processes that are occurring
within these individual tumor states and
that is a benefited quite a bit from a
number of levels and i think one
particular aspect has been the ability
to be able to share that data in a way
that has allowed a number of folks to
start investigating and interrogating
tumor types and really building up a
compendium that can be applied and so it
speaks to the tumor registry aspects
that are occurring on at a number of
companies and a number of institutions
that I think will help to drive that but
there are limitations within the
approach itself and you know some of the
data that has come out and published on
even being able to create models that
predict risk by looking just a clinical
data can be very powerful even more
powerful than the actual genomic data
that comes along with those attributes
so let's become very important things to
understand and how that actually can
impact on where we are I don't know if
there's any questions yet but office I
just looked over just to see so some of
the key issues that we are facing that's
finding the hub gene target as obviously
as many folks understand really
identifying that and those carrier or
the genes that are not really specific
with regards to us an endpoint are also
and can be mutated in those analyses and
so really finding the hub gene target of
being able to target that in a way
therapeutic ly becomes a very
significant endpoint addition to not
only targeting but also to understanding
the mechanisms of resistance and overall
risk components just like we me inherent
clinical molecular heterogeneity of
disease is I think a very important
variable that is overlooked in many
cases with regards to the genomic
aspects and really having a billet II to
do that on a genomic level from
to somatic and then introducing the
environmental pieces as well as the
elements of the tissue itself become
very important there's a number of
relevant phenotypes that have produced
some false positives and so that's
something that has to be mitigated as we
approach these issues from a clinical
genomic strategy and others and so it's
it's ways to improve upon our abilities
to statistically analyze these areas but
also create large enough cohort data
that can actually be deployed
effectively the ability to look at multi
domain data elements is an important
aspect that we all face the term big
data has obviously been a somewhat
abused over the years in terms of its
role and I think what those of us that
were involved in the personalized
medicine space when it first started
also feel the same issues that impacted
personalized medicine in terms of the
word have impacted on big data but those
are things that we need to really
address to understand how to look at
that data effectively and then obviously
the ability to prospectively validate in
current drug program and clinical trials
and that's something that is quite
challenging as everyone on the phone and
online probably understands that there
needs to be motivation from the
biopharmaceutical sector and then it is
a complex trial design which is not
trivial to produce so as a pathologist
we are incumbent on the anatomy and the
pathology to help drive our
understanding of disease we overlay that
with something that we produced a while
ago when I was with a company that
looked at and tried to get at some of
the elements that you could derive from
the tissue and equate those to a
molecular piece and the microarray
strategies that were initiated quite a
number of years ago but overlaying those
on the human anatomy was a critical
piece but as we all know there are
challenges with that entire context that
I just went through in from a pathology
department perspective there are a
number of issues we you know reading
clinical regulatory needs as an
oversight of everything that happens in
a clinical dept drives some of the
processes that will be developed in the
technology research space so there are
needs to be managed programs at
setters that can incorporate internal
research programs we're attracting
appropriate human capital as well as NIH
dollars and philanthropic support to
maintain that and pathology departments
and academic centers are competing in a
very demanding healthcare environment
and so we need to create a consultative
information synthesizing clinical dept
that can drive that as opposed to the
more traditional epidemic technology
departments and this gets to some of the
challenges of us meeting that
personalized medicine space and as you
can tell being a pathologist i put the
pathologist in the center of that entire
process so the department of pathology
new structure i'll go through this
rather quickly is to look at the
traditional ways of service anatomic AP
clinical pathology CP and then the
molecular technology in the center so
the interface between those two so this
is really the traditional view of most
departments of pathology there is an
educational research piece that's
present there as well and that is
involved with a number of activities
that look at students resident fellows
and faculty monitoring element but
another element and i think at aspect of
the next generation pathology of the
future is really to have an experimental
pathology element and component to it
which has both an intramural and
extramural piece and what do I mean by
that so the intramural element is really
driving activities drawing upon the
rivest and rich resource of information
critical data and the environment that
we're in to be able to develop both
novel Diagnostics therapeutics really be
able to deploy a number of from an
investigational sense through
appropriate IRB channels the right
studies that can actually start to
create some informative information then
the other piece is the extra mural side
and that's bringing in novel
technologies that are really just
getting started or are fairly mature but
have not met clinical rigor and this
puts them into an environment where they
actually can be understood and further
analyzed and that becomes a very
important component I think of the next
gen technology department
and obviously with all of that is the IT
or in your institutional support for
that computational power to be able to
pull all that information together and
use that effectively in modeling becomes
a very critical aspect of this and here
we also overlay the institutional
biorepository piece which i believe is a
element that is somewhat overlooked and
most centers in terms of making it
comprehensive this is not just a fluid
based biorepository but it is a tissue
disease specific project specific based
by a repository that can drive that and
that's what we really push forward here
to be able to deploy this in a way that
is global across the that's on a
healthcare system but then also pulls on
various disease states and this is not
just tumor but also other diseases
because there is quite a bit of
intersect in the evolution of more
diseases that may have an end result
which is cancer like inflammatory bowel
disease and ulcerative colitis so having
mechanisms to understand that dissect it
and then integrate that becomes an
important element and so we created a
biorepository pathology core function
which helps us to understand those
elements as well as the molecular
pathology piece and those become
integrated in a way where you can drive
research and discovery efforts to
clinical efforts so functioning almost
as a biotech in within the context of a
academic and next gen clinical pathology
department so at a variety of
technologies and services that we were
able to provide but we really the
investigational pieces to meet a variety
of elements that are linked to a trial
or a disease process or an understanding
of that so using a variety of different
types of formats of collection processes
help us to begin to build those
necessary bags so it pulls back some of
that tumor registry that I was thinking
about with the TCGA but doing that
internally in a much more comprehensive
way and in a much more real-time fashion
as well and then this is linked to a
pathology core element which functions
in a capacity to be able to drive some
of the analytic processes that will get
at some
those functional identification and
phenotyping of the individual genes and
proteins that are coming out of a
variety of disease states that are being
put together by the repository so you
can see this becomes a very integrative
collective that drives some of these
activities now molecular pathology it
obviously has been a significant aspect
of pathology departments and it is
evolving as it must with regards to
clinical genomics driving these
activities which is being emphasized in
a variety of efforts across the entire
healthcare system so it enables us to be
more precise in our diagnosis and
classification it provides prognostic
information it can define molecular
targets for therapy or not allowing
monitoring the therapeutic response
which is becoming more of an important
aspect as we understand the targeted
therapy and its limitations stratifying
risk for disease development is an
important component as well as building
in an informed kinetic counseling piece
especially for the hereditary cancers
and the pathogenic variants that become
very important as we try to pull this
process together now of course there are
challenges with regards to this
molecular pathology program and over the
years this has been quite a traditional
of doing in some would even lump
immunised of chemistry as a molecular
pathology piece because you're looking
at a protein and result of a molecular
pathway so that being said you would
have in situ hybridization as being part
of these processes this is sort of the
what has been done and still occurring
with regards to various fish type
analyses and translocations that become
very important in the liquid tumors as
well as in the solid malignancies most
recently and then overlaying that with a
variety of activities has helped to
drive some of the understanding of the
genetic and genomic approaches that can
be brought to bear on the disease
process of interest but with that have
become so I think excellent success
stories obviously for the her to ER and
PR as biomarkers that have been an
evolved to the point of being quite
successful in there
and I am limiting this summit to the
solid tumors and not focusing on the
hematologic malignancies here just to
folks understand and as you can see the
rat v600e melanoma EGFR and the
activating mutations in AML for alcon
lung cancer now Ross as well as EGFR k
rats and rats in colon the unused of the
Oncotype DX test for breast colon and
prostate as well as and I put PSA here
because it is currently unit as a
biomarker it is a strategy that folks
use to actually do an invasive
procedures such as a biopsy but is that
really a success story as a challenge
obviously and even with all of these
there are attributes that will not give
you the complete story with regards to
that patient so you will get windows of
opportunity with regards to the use of a
therapeutic but you must understand that
there are both elements of that tumor
heterogeneity that I mentioned and that
heterogeneity at the molecular level as
well as in them the response of the
patient that impacts on these processes
and it's important to really understand
that so most recently I think that we've
all learned that precision oncology is
evolving and as I mentioned and
hopefully you'll understand and the
respective pathology departments
involving genomics is evolving as well
and the past am I you know the use of
imatinib in CML as you know for driven I
think a variety of activities that we
are understand as being a wonderful
perfect storm of smart scientists and
that relatively simple cancer looking at
a specific translocation and then
getting a very effective drug with
tremendously positive results that's a
that was a huge success and I think that
it's it's not you know in any way
diminished in terms of where we're going
it just gives you an idea of that you
need that collective to really have that
perfect storm in that success it's very
important to understand that not every
activating and every mutation is an
activating mutation and not all drugs
that block protein function hall growth
and even though we would love to think
that it isn't really the reality that we
pay
and I think that that's becoming true
and the more we understand that the more
I think that drive home the true
personalized care and that that true
effort of being able to impact on
disease the element of basket trials had
as I think many are familiar with this
histology agnostic approach and that
means finding just a mutation in various
tumor types and then treating patients
with the drug for that specific mutation
would be a huge success and in some
respects it is but in others it is not
in colorectal cancer with the be roughly
600 inhibitors has not been a tremendous
success and so it it does lend pause to
for you to understand that even though
we would love to just dismiss the
histopathology peace and disco after as
a histology agnostic government may not
be the most appropriate thing to do in
general and cross all tumor types and so
I think we have to be tumor-specific
there and rather than histology agnostic
the recent Shiva trial in last year by
Lord to know at all I think was a
awakener for some of us others not
because we believe that that was the
case this is the first randomized trial
in precision oncology so this is really
looking at the role that different
therapeutics would be able to play by
using off-label use of drugs in that
setting and it really challenges some of
the views that we would have in terms of
the types of mutations that you would
drive an understanding from versus the
standard of care in chemotherapy and
that it not is not always better and I
think we it does get to some of the
various editorials surrounding the trial
which we're looking at things like all
of the mutant versus Collin Eaton
cancers and the poly mutant cancers may
have and are of a different phenotype
and may be better served by different
types of targeted therapies multimodal
therapy things like that so it's it's
ways for us to understand the evolution
that we're seeing with regards to both
specific diseases
as well as the types of therapies we
thought we apply so I think we have some
very you know interesting ways to look
at some of these approaches and
certainly there have been true successes
and the evolution of cancer
classification especially in lung cancer
has driven and changed how we actually
approach that disease and I think
molecular subtyping of that disease has
been an important characteristic for
therapeutic indication and it has been
quite significant and on the next slide
here you'll see the role that the egfr
activating mutations has played with
regards to specific drugs such as
competitive in refractory lung cancer
patients and the dramatic responses that
we see are a testimony to the
understanding of the disease the
phenotype of the disease and the
molecular characteristics of that
disease and that becomes a very
important element of what you try to
accomplish when we approach these from a
molecular technology perspective now
obviously getting this into the
guidelines is important from a variety
of perspectives I think it helps to sort
of standardized the approach to
management of patients but it also lends
credence and support to the aspects of
these various mutations in specific
disease states and this just as the NCCN
guidelines for a lung cancer and listing
to various egfr as well as chaos and elk
components that are required now to be
able to stratify patients and understand
their response given that some of these
are resistance mutations such as t790m
and is that the best serve through a
tissue based biopsy approach or should
those be really evaluated more from the
liquid biopsy perspective and not
subjecting the patient to biopsies post
treatment so this gets into some of the
challenges that I think we face is
technologist because I think we need to
embrace these newer technologies because
they will be driving the elements of how
we play a central role in all of these
activities to that point I think it's
interesting to note that at least in
prostate cancer the role that the
circulating tumor cell has played with
regards to antigen receptor splice
variants
the resistance mechanisms that those
play with regards to therapeutic
androgen signaling pathway inhibitors
such as enzalutamide and ever at around
and it's important to see that those
were identified really and circulating
tumor cells obviously the splice variant
arv 7 has become the significant one and
there are antibodies to this and there
are ways to understand it but you know
these are post-treatment elements and so
they become very important in that
liquid biopsy sent space and there's a
number of methodologies that can be
brought to bear on that not just in the
circulating tumor cells side but I
believe in exercise as well that help to
put forth some of those attributes and
understanding as well as the complexity
with this and well over we focus on a
rv7 there are many that believe that the
splice variants themselves are
collectively responsible for some of the
mechanisms of resistance so there's a
lot happening in this area I think it's
a really an important aspect for us to
understand as molecular pathologists as
next-gen technologists that we won't
deploy and understand these various
components as we manage our patients you
know and I've been around a while to
know that you know we all did the grind
and find approach and function to really
drive genomic and transcriptomic
understanding and you know starting with
that high content on the left-hand side
of the screen here which really it's
interesting and we don't have time to go
into the specifics but how we actually
approach some of the the analytes at the
end of using in our final assays is
quite interesting and it needs to be
sort of understood that these will have
limitations associated with them and
that we are left to trust at the right
side of the screen what is our readouts
from these particular approaches and so
with that I think there is a challenge
to try to put this in the context of
disease and the complexity of disease
that we can always hope to be able to
derive information from these high
content approaches that are our
riddick approaches and our ability to be
able to integrate this data with other
data streams becomes as important as the
technology itself one significant aspect
of this is really tumor heterogeneity
and I think that I've been very nice
studies on this and they've published on
it as well to start understanding tumor
heterogeneity at the clonal genomic
level but also at the tissue level and
the histology level and what that really
means and how we can drive that then and
that understanding with respect to
individual patients so there are
obviously individual molecular
properties and subclones that are
present within tumors and the importance
of those is dependent upon a variety of
attributes and that's where some of
those resistance mechanisms that I
alluded to even with egfr on t790m or
the resistance of alpha pathways become
significant post-treatment because you
may be removing some of these subclones
and then it is a resistant form that
remains so we really have to have a
better understanding of what that means
and now feel quite a few years ago we
had established an idea and a premise
surrounding systems pathology which is
involved too precise pathology and and
that really takes into consideration the
intact tissue specimen and the
attributes of that tissue specimen and
the morphometry the quantitative
assessment of that becomes very
important as an understanding of their
variables that are associated with
disease and I think dismissing that and
just grinding that up is really a
disservice to the biology and to the
patient because I think that we're not
gleaning as much information as we
possibly could so we created this as a
methodology and linked it with a
component of multiplex
immunofluorescence strategies which
created quantitative features and then
use the clinical data that was available
for those patients and integrated that
with advanced mathematic techniques that
are now I think becoming more invoke and
understood that helps you to derive
these accurate predictive and prognostic
risk models and so there's a number of a
so that that become important but just
to give you a sense of what that looks
like if you did object based
morphometric image analysis on a biopsy
from prostate cancer patient and here
you'll see in this image a lot of color
and you'll see green of predominantly
and then you'll see gold and the green
is reflective of cytokeratin positivity
so they're all set a current and
positive but the ones that are gold are
actually a combination of lace mace this
is a enzyme that's associated with the
prostate cancer disease so uh components
of a high-grade pin to prostate cancer
has an increased amount of racemase and
so you can see this quite a bit of
heterogeneity just in prostate cancer
which morphologically by H&E looks quite
similar but when you start getting down
to the phenotype of it it's quite
different and then that can be drill
down even further by looking at androgen
receptor components and the other colors
there the red the blue and the pink are
representative of the levels of androgen
receptor that are present by
immunofluorescence and so you can see
that some cells have very high levels of
antigen receptor and some have very very
low to none and that that disc that
differential becomes very important and
not going into what's happening in the
stroma but the stroma itself also
becomes very important in these
processes so the point being really to
have an understanding of this becomes
very critical in our view of disease and
how we can actually deploy that and
hopefully you can see that if you take
that and if you grind all that up you
will miss attributes of that particular
phenotype now some would argue that they
may not be important attributes for that
patient and that we would find something
that's driving the disease process that
may be so for a period of time but
there's other elements there that will
be missed and things like cancer stem
cell activity and the presence of cancer
stem cells and the load of cancer stem
cells can become quite important and
this can be applied in a number of ways
and I think you could look at this and
we did study it's not only just in
prostate but in ovarian cancer using the
multiplex with cytokeratins where you
can create a mask and then you can start
looking at the cell signaling activity
and so in this case we're looking at
more oncogenic activity and looking for
mutations in p53 as well as the
presence of phosphorylated work in a
pathway sense and you can see just by
this is looking at this in different
colors that the set of keratin image
itself instead of counting seven is
identified with that magenta or pink
color which is present again in this
image here but then p53 as you'll see is
in red so there's a distribution of p53
mutant present within the ovarian cancer
and then the phosphorylated Kirk is
present in the nuclei and concentrated
within the nucleus as well as in the
membrane of some of the cells within the
ovarian cancer but not in all of them so
a subset are actually have that activity
so it gets that some of that again that
level of complexity because you can
drive those features quantitatively and
then put them in models and see if there
is importance and relevance and this can
be done simply even by looking and using
morphometry and doing the hie on a liver
section which is seen in this image here
so this is from a study where you were
looking at more of a toxicology with
respect to impact on liver attributes
and the HMA image itself for the
pathologist online there's diatonic
present so there's a queue walls which
are present within the impetus sites you
can submit that segment that on a scale
so you can create a view of what the
actual vacuoles look like and then you
can create a heat map of that which is
the last image which looks at the degree
of steatosis so it gets to some of the
liver injury but it's putting that into
a quantitative place as opposed to a
subjective space which is quite
important as you move these processes
forward now we're continuing to advance
the aspect of understanding morphometry
here in a precise pathology group at
Mount Sinai and this looks at ways to
expand our view of how to decide for
cancer how to decipher histopathology by
using Voronoi diagrams which is some of
the ways in which you could start
constructing assessment of gland
structure if you will in an
adenocarcinoma can't go into too much
detail but using these techniques you're
able to then look at degrees of
differentiation or on differentiation
with respect
to add no carcinoma for example in other
ways and we recently had an abstracted
ask of GU and that other since then that
have used the features that are present
within this morphometry derived from
these glands to start constructing
models of outcome and then if you
overlay that with the androgen receptor
expression profiles at the protein level
you can get some very different ways to
start sorting out an understanding
disease manifestation by combining
morphometry histopathology and biomarker
attributes and that really is the
essence of the precise pathology
insistence technology piece so a lot of
those efforts I think are driving yet
another resurgence again in single cell
sequencing data and understanding of how
that looks and there's been a further
push to do this and we have that ongoing
here in a variety of disease states
where to start looking at single cells
and really getting at some of the
numeral heterogeneity piece and
exploiting that further obviously very
challenging with a number of elements to
it that are a little difficult to talk
about in this session but certainly
something to think about as we move
through the space that single cell
sequencing is an important component and
in concert with that I think we'll have
an understanding of some of the elements
were circulating tumor cells become an
important part of that single cell
research space as well as the idea of
the cancer stem cell theory and that
that the limited number of a population
of cells which are inherently chemo
resistant and I have the potential for
driving disease post treatment and I
think those are important elements to be
understood that will continue to evolve
as we learn more about them now
technologies are picking up with that
and when I was at another company quite
a few years ago we use laser capture
microdissection quite a bit to
understand individual and collections of
cells and disease processes this is
looking at a natural erotic plaques or
not obviously cancer related or we do
send some call this cancer of the
vessels is that it it allows you to a
good technique that has now evolved to
be
quite robust and relatively standardized
you can micro two stacks individual cell
population you can use
immunohistochemistry to identify the
specific cell populations in isolate
those you can analyze them at the DNA
level the RNA level so it really opens
up that whole space of single cell
sequencing it opens up the whole space
of understanding that in the context of
disease and tumor heterogeneity and I
think it will become and continue to be
an important from time now as you heard
me mention the cancer stem cell
hypotheses that Carlos Quentin Pardo and
his group have continued to push forward
and they make compelling arguments of
the presence of cancer stem cells that
in this view here are cytokeratin
negative cells so it's a negative cell
population not differentiated cells that
are present within tumors in this cases
is prostate cancer high-grade prostate
cancer and then looking at these cells
with multiplex immunofluorescence
strategies you can start to see that
there are components of the beta-catenin
pathway present you can merge these you
can understand that cell population a
little better so that becomes a very
interesting attribute and that by
looking at the numbers of those cells in
different types of grades of gleason
cancer for prostate here you'll see that
they are very reflective of poor outcome
with the higher the number of these
cancer stem cells suggesting that that
tumor load that we speak about is not
just a tumor load in general but it's a
tumor load with respect to the stem cell
hypothesis and I think that's an
important element that should be further
evaluated and continue to be exploited
now switching gears ellipta a little bit
to go towards the liquid biopsy
applications and how those are seen to
play a role in these various activities
and I think that the liquid biopsy space
continues to evolve from some of the
early efforts which were focusing on
circulating tumor cell biology and some
of the systems that were deployed in
classical departments of pathology and
clinical laboratories to be able to
quantify or enumerate the circulating
tumor cell was a
naskah but the liquid biopsy piece
really is reflective of everything
that's going on in fluids so it's really
just not restricted to your circulating
tumor cell population so you'll have
circulating tumor cells you'll have
circulating cell-free DNA which I think
a lot of people are mine have heard
about now there's home meetings at
droidcon about this as well as the x's
ohms which are the multi particular
derived free-floating but really intact
plasma membrane vessels that are out in
all fluid spaces that allow us to start
understanding the roles that these
individual components play within
disease processes self a cell
communication and really are a
reflection of what's happening at the
systemic level which is something that
it's impossible to do really as I we
hope you understand at the tissue level
but yet it is another variable that
needs to be included in this whole
process and so there's a number of
aspects here of looking at various ways
in which these types of activities can
be understood and I think at the review
of a therapeutic decision point where
these types of approaches can be
evaluated if you don't have enough
tissue to be able to make a diagnosis
whether there is out present let's say
or there are easy of our mutations
present within a particular sample if
you find you'll ask for from a patient
sample at the time of diagnosis with
lung cancer this becomes very critical
because otherwise you will have no
diagnostic material to make that
decision correlating with tumor stage
becomes very important because you have
another way to evaluate the level of
dissemination of their cells within the
body and that's an important new
evolution of different time points also
becomes quite important you'd like to
know that how the dynamics of the
disease are progressing and and what's
happening parts treatment and during
treatment and then review of obviously
tumor recurrence becomes very important
as we further manage these patients and
how the these will be deployed in
various therapeutic and even novel
therapies is still be coming I think of
even more significance as we try to run
Durst
checkpoint inhibitors in the role of PDL
one status within tumors all very
important components so as I was
alluding to that micro vesicle
communication with exosomes has been
well established in the literature
there's quite a number of publications
on this from various independent groups
that have validated the methodology
behind the noose and utility of
microvesicles they have one of the
discreet I think indistinct advantages
is the aspect of RNA and I think we
sometimes overlook the RNA piece because
of its complexity and its instability
but it does and represent a very
significant aspect of where we need to
be heading and I think anything that
helps us to get there with regards to
whether it's in vitro diagnostics that
look at RNA or other methodologies is
important because that becomes a very
relevant aspect of the disease phenotype
and there's this as a fairly complex
slide but it has it's a number of these
points I think that you can see of how
these can be used at different elements
or understood at different points and
disease from the relevance for
angiogenesis as well as the auto crime
signaling to just in tumor cells so that
level of communication becomes a very
important component and another one I
think is fast advancing is really the
use in immunosuppression and
understanding that immune complex aspect
becomes very critical and there are
additional technologies here from the
pep dynamic space that will also be
important to drive these understanding
and developing these models but it gives
you the idea that the fluid space is
quite complex but rich with data that we
need to really understand and in the
essence of the exosome biology piece
what we thought you know I started out
as all electron microscopist and so when
we saw these on cells it look like junk
on the cells but they actually were that
budding vesicles that were actually
derived from these multivesicular bodies
as well as other processes that its
first identified in GD images that
glioblastoma multiforme a microvesicles
and then using electron microscopy in
various techniques you can identify the
size of the
exosomes as well as you can detect out
the contents and get a very really rich
understanding of disease processes in
that state the exosomes themselves
become biomarkers for disease and you'll
look at these for a number of
fingerprints of disease that we can use
and they can be deployed to it
understand the traditional mutations
that we see in derived from DNA so k
ravi ravi GF are in different disease
states as well as a fingerprint of
disease and that snapshot that I was
alluding to and so that becomes
important because I think we can
understand where these fit with regards
to the role that these play in that
diagnostic and more strategy for
monitoring space and they both they can
be deployed in in those areas
effectively the other element is a
circulating tumor cell biology component
that's went from enumeration which I
mentioned before so the counting of
cells still be is an important element
for you know that understanding of your
disease prognosis and the larger the
number of cells and of a cut point the
worse your statuses and associated with
more advanced stage and possibly
non-response to standard therapy so it
becomes important to understand that
that evolves over time to linking it up
to molecular diagnostics and I think
that's where it becomes quite
significant as we move that needle from
just enumeration to really phenotyping
and then characterization at the
molecular level becomes quite important
for that process and so technologies
that can do that and do it in an open
way and I think that's gets that summer
what I was alluding to with the cancer
stem cell theories that those are cells
that will not have traditional cell
surface markers like cytokeratins so
they can't be isolated that way and they
will have other properties associated
with them that maybe morphological
properties as well as pathway properties
and to dissect those effectively isolate
that cell population will require or
open technologies that are being
developed and this is just an example of
one of those that does it through a chip
process and has methodologies where you
can pop out different antibodies and be
able to do this on a micro
chip where you can evaluate that the
self cells that you've isolated you know
typically but then I think the beauty of
taking this level from a phenotypic
perspective and linking it to downstream
activities is quite important so these
becoming irrelevant for us to understand
the populations of cells that were
actually isolating and there's been a
number of publications on this that have
moved that needle forward and its
continued to progress and I think of
importance it will do that so that you
will be able to understand and see what
these components mean and there are
clearly distinguished from the
leukocytes and the general blood
population of cells so they do exist and
then now it's a matter of further
characterizing those for the future and
so we here have fun use the Ion Torrent
platform in the hot spot in our clinical
cancer sequencing element and to have a
program on the liquid biopsy space that
it's linked to that is a very attractive
element for us and so that becomes a way
from a clinical and a research lab piece
that I mentioned during that the
next-gen pathology element to take
attributes that were just beginning to
understand from the circulating tumor
cell space and evolve those to a
platform that can we can isolate the DNA
from the circulating tumor cell you can
collect cell-free DNA from the systems
and you can also isolate genomic DNA so
now you get three attributes of that
particular patients material in one you
can visualize you can phenotype and now
you can actually molecular the
characterizing from a flow perspective
in a department as well as sort of
phenotyping perspective these become
quite significant to do and so there's a
number of ways in which these approaches
from the liquid biopsy space will evolve
and will continue to evolve and you'll
see different platforms that will look
at this sample stability and
standardisation become important in a
clinical environment and so getting the
sample to us these are non tissue
samples so it's a is a bit tricky and
this is a group that actually fixes
those samples so we're able to then be
able to do that in a way that is quite
little
must and that allows us to time from
collection to analysis there needs to be
ways in which you could effectively not
have contamination between samples and
then that it can read the number of the
attributes here that are important in
these processes and I think that's
thrives of relative activities so the
game changer really is that use of these
in decision processes becomes a very
important component there are challenges
with these as you could imagine I went
through the whole process of tumor
heterogeneity so there you go I mean
this will be yet another attribute and
all of those components of circulating
tumor cells 2 x's ohms to cell free DNA
will all play a role in that process and
that objective transition from ctc
enumeration to actual characterization
will be critical and then the ability to
be able to do this in a robust
environment is important the other piece
of that puzzle that with the liquid
biopsy is the cell-free DNA aspect and
the ability to look at that in the
context of circulating tumor cells
becomes important because you can then
use two different physiological
mechanisms to drive an understanding or
fizzies and it's a just gives you this
in a cartoon fashion of what this looks
like from the different attributes that
are floating around in your blood and
how they are actually derived is an
important aspect whether they are butted
off from populations or cells carry with
possibly immune related activity such as
the circulating tumor cell peace with
their shed from tumor cells by active
growth and the change in the status of
that cell population to a Mormon sin
comer or mobile self as well as then the
cell-free DNA which is a pop tonic or
ischemic and aquatic mechanisms or by
direct extrusion from the cell if you
are so inclined so those are different
ways in which you can actually get those
attributes within the fluid and then how
to exploit those and then the last
obviously is emphasizing the exosome
piece which carries that whole complex
DNA on the surface but also has proteins
and has rich micro RNA and mrnas of the
transcriptome so it plays yet a whole
nother level of understanding to
whatever I'm trying to investigate
genomics obviously has the germline
piece that helps us to understand
ctc and cell-free DNA components and so
that's important for the analytic side
to be able to use the variants that are
present within the germline and look at
those and evaluate those in the context
of the cell-free DNA and the ctc DNA so
having those systems to be able to do
this robustly and to create that
analytic platform is a very important
component of this so we've gone into a
number of a drug activities with various
folks and one is a sylvania which looks
at that ability it's linked to the
hotspot panel but it also does it in a
way that allows you to have somewhat of
an open platform for phenotyping disease
and I think linking that to the hotspot
allows you to get a very unique
understanding of patients and I'm not
going to go into much detail here do the
time but looking at patients pre and
post material you can start getting a
sense that this is pretreatment and then
post treatment that there are different
mutations that are present in the pre
material that may not be present in the
post material and that comparable
mutations may be present in both the
their CTCs which has a p53 mutation in
this case and then the cell-free DNA is
the same p53 mutation so those
concordant activities help to understand
some of the roles that these play but
the discordant also helps to understand
some of those roles in a and lets you
understand insight into the complexity
that we're trying to process so we are
doing this at a triple negative breast
cancer trial to drive some of these
processes forward to really push that
envelope of understanding subcommittee
tumor cell self read ian and then
including the natural killer cell
activity through an Eliza essay as well
so again you can bring in a fluid based
approach that crosses all avenues from
the genomic side that I've went through
you can then use exosomes in the context
of this as well as then looking at cell
populations and may be very relevant
with respect to understanding disease
outcome and prognosis so in summary of
what I've hopefully have convinced you
that the genomic profiling of solid
tumors is only
one aspect of patient-specific nina
typing and i think that that's an
important element that is missed and i
think it needs to be addressed and it
needs to be addressed at the protein
level it needs to be addressed that the
RNA level i needs to be addressed at the
historic ology level I think those
become critical aspects of this
pathology departments must adapt to
become the true gatekeepers for precise
medicine we must as pathologists move
this needle forward we are the
gatekeepers we the ones can decide that
which essay should be performed for
individual patients because we
understand the elements and the
underpinnings of the technology and how
it can be deployed effectively in his
face that's my opinion liquid biopsy I
think is a critical aspect of patient
assessment lucu the exosome circulating
tumor cells proteomics metabolomics all
are aspects to me of the liquid biopsy
space it's not just a genomic component
of this I think it's all aspects of this
are important and that technologies that
are robust accurate and demonstrate
efficacy will advance this space going
forward and will continue to evolve this
space as we go through so what I see is
the future you know we have serum
screening you'll have your the exosome
biology piece as we see up top here with
the circulating tumor cell piece as well
as very relevant to understanding our
activities and what we're trying to
decipher the proteomics element of that
becomes very important as well as we
bring in other components such as
imaging and I think imaging especially
in prostate cancer with the MRI and the
use of really in directed imaging will
help to remove some of our sampling
problems and get it through molecular
imaging more targeted approaches for
lesion assessment and then overlaying
that with as I went through which was
the systems pathology precise pathology
piece using morphometry using
immunofluorescence or multiplex
chromogenic attributes of cells will add
so much information to these activities
and really decipher out the pathways
that are actually turned on that we can
understand and then
they impact on with the true with
therapeutic response and that is the
last slide and I thank you very much for
your attention thank you dr. Donovan for
bringing that important information to
us before we get started on questions
I'm just going to remind our audience
how they can submit their questions
questions can be submitted by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window and type
in your question in the box will be
posing the questions to dr. Donovan
verbally and he'll be able to follow
along with the text and answer your
questions so our first question here
comes from an attendee and they ask what
role do you think learning about
nutrient dependent micro RNAs and
rna-mediated cell type differentiation
will play in differentiating between the
molecular mechanisms of energy dependent
healthy longevity and pathology that
question is available for dr. Donovan to
read through
certainly I feel like the RNA element
and it's how it's actually driven by the
physiologic environment that think
you're alluding to with this nutrient
dependent micro RNA aspect and the
ability for micrornas to modulate the
genomic transcription level will become
very I think are very important
attributes that I think difficult to
detect in a human condition but
certainly through investigational
approaches I think that will have
tremendous insight into the I think
understanding of what role that they
play but I do believe that RNA
transcript omics in general will be very
important in our approach to phenotyping
and medicine in general
great we have our we have our next
question up in the box for dr. Donovan
which sample type is most appropriate
for genomic profiling liquid biopsies
solid tumor serum whole blood saliva or
other body fluid ecology departments has
been the solid tumor of these because
that's the the most accessible that is
available for the majority of
departments of pathology and even
community practice settings so you can
do quite a bit with the formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded material in a genomic
setting and get reliable data from that
and that that can be effective because
we would love to be able to have fresh
frozen tissue available to us so the
solid tumor but at a fresh frozen level
would be better than the fixed issue
it's just it's much more challenging to
get that from the majority of the
department's pretty much not only the US
but in Europe as well and probably the
world so given that context was I think
that they serve a very important role in
understanding that the liquid biopsy
piece certainly you know I'm a big
believer in urine samples and we just
got a publication actually in that
engine oncology that looked at urine
exosome biology with respect to prostate
cancer and so I think that certainly you
can isolate these elements within fluids
and derive some very valuable
information from them as we're seeing in
urine I think liquid biopsy material is
also quite good the complex body fluids
are I think best evaluated in that in
the context of some of the newer
technologies that are being able to look
at phage display and be able to pull out
specific elements within the those at
those aspects but they are more
complicated and certainly saliva is also
a rich source for exosomes it's a rich
source for DNA it's a rich source for
proteins and there are a number of
interesting publications that actually
can do have used that in
head neck cancer and even lung cancer so
i think that there's waves in which
those become very important aspects of
our monitoring of disease even of the
early stage potentially for screening of
disease thank you dr. Donovan that is at
the time we have right now for questions
I just want to pass it back to dr.
Donovan to see if he has any final
comments for our audience today on his
topic the messages of where i believe
the pathologist's it's in this respect
the complexity of disease that we're
facing and that the ability to be able
to deploy new technologies to look at
this from a variety of perspectives will
be so important as we try to derive our
understanding of disease biology and
outcome because really the end result is
the patient and we need to be I think
and understand what we say and how we
say it with regards to some of our what
I think are miraculous ways to be able
to impact on disease but I think we need
to really convey that in such a fashion
that this is a complex process and we're
sort of making definitely making
progress in headway but we need to I
think do more thank you very much
thank you dr. Donovan certainly a lot of
good information in your talk today I
want to thank dr. Donovan for bringing
this information to us and for taking
time to make this presentation I also
want to thank lab routes comm for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand replay through October of 2716
you'll receive an email from lab roots
when this webcast is available for
on-demand replay and we invite you to
forward that email to your colleagues
who might have missed today's live event
thank you again for logging on and being
with us today we hope you see you again
goodbye